so you're going to hear a lot of
shouting uh
coming down the road behind me in fact
it is a
i think it's a procession of uh
of the taliban uh yes it is there's the
white flag
and uh they're coming down uh the street
uh just next to us they're in their
shames they're led by a white flag um
and uh they're chanting uh as they as
they go go down i don't think from our
position
we can't show you that uh jonathan
they're about we're about two or three
stories uh four stories up but there
they are right here uh
hopefully
they keep going past this hotel i can't
see
i can't see people with weapons at all
doesn't mean they're not but they're
they're not openly carrying um guns as
far as i can tell
and uh they are marching uh and and
chanting
so you couldn't ask for a better
illustration of the fact uh that the
taliban aren't just um in kabul but
they're actually right right in the
center of it they've just have just
walked past uh the presidential palace
uh which is there so um
interesting times you know we're not
it's are they just parading around are
these taliban fighters that have come in
uh from other areas again we don't know
that it could be that they are actual
taliban supporters who just lived here
so we just don't know i think the power
has just gone on this so
i'll hang back
you